welcome to this game playing water water
from Argentina yeah so one of those guys
is from the nation of the current world
football champion don't know yet don't
know yet if it's germany argentina at
the time of the recording so when you
see this you know more than I do ok so
we have a Reggie opening here i'm going
to whoops going to play with efore ok
this is a possible line for black fairly
fairly solid way to play I think this
was played in any game not exactly this
line it was the same structure in a game
between Carlton and kayaking I think two
thousand and twelve or thirteen and no
invite on same one of cards and sir best
games i have covered this probably on
video somewhere a great great technical
performance very much reminiscent of
bobby fischer's ok so how to evaluate
this probably this is about equal i'd
like to get some play against against
the screen side like with before but
it's not easy to do yeah black so he is
ok yeah he's got a good good active
pieces maybe
difficult difficult to make any headway
we should be four it's not a good
structure really yeah that's really a
nothing position but this is also what
happened two cars in this and the
mentioned game he had pretty much
nothing but then he started to slowly ya
grind grind kayaking down all right it's
very really nothing they don't be three
is quite quite an annoyance maybe still
I can can can use this we should before
idea but I don't really see how know
can't do anything him
I can basically just sit in wait maybe
I'm i can't play play e for some time
getting getting some space it takes
takes rook takes exists at least
exchanges stuff don't know
takes bishop takes my GSD 45 he's not
really in a good position to block on d5
so maybe this is okay
and starting to like my position now
maybe maybe not not justified but it
looks this looks like why does having
having some edge he must have made a
mistake there somewhere it was certainly
a certainly a good position for him now
now this is very weird very
uncomfortable and he absolutely must
take what I'm not sure what he is
thinking about him I mean takes Bishop
takes is very awkward for him but he
still probably has to invest and play it
yeah I thought we should be three wood
would turn lead to to an excellent
position I will get the beep on there's
something better Bishop g5 is also good
but this looks like a relatively clean
technical win I of course he couldn't
even take here because I can take with
the bishop and he I have Bishop g4 check
there is no counter play right let's
just briefly check takes rook takes
Bishop a three I can return to you one
song yeah I can do that black forfeits
duty disconnection okay who's really
happens happens a lot yeah I mean okay
here here black is totally fine
absolutely fine it's a it's very
comfortable from like you can just I
mean if it does not want to do anything
he can just sit in wait there is
absolutely no one sorry no active
way forward I mean here here and
probably he should just maybe he
shouldn't take after the capture I mean
this is this is really awkward I get in
this to get the sin and this is and then
I'm suddenly enjoying the two bishops in
an open position and the night on be
three years is misplaced quite
remarkable he should probably do this d
4 and something like this to have c5
against d5 here probably wouldn't play d
5 but try to improve the position maybe
this is a good idea look III bishop d1
something like that and here after the
five-year widest winning after d5
amazing he has no one no defence iam I
mean this is what's a winning and here i
made a calculation mistake initially I
thought that after this I go rook to e1
and and win the endgame probably I'll do
this this wins b3 and I won't be seven
this is probably a technical win but not
not so quick gamma cannon something like
this but this is of course idiotic I
can't just stick with the bishop and I
had over overlooked this initially okay
thanks for watching